Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Mono. Now, according to
this game everything is watching you and
we know what you did, you shouldn't have
done that thing. How dare you even click
on this video? Well now that you're here
your only punishment is to be
subjected to whatever the hell Mono is
al- not the disease, I mean I'm talking
about this game here that we're going to play and i'm actually gonna
just gonna..
There we go! it finally took it took a little bit
Hello, the developer of Mono here. Thank you
for buying my game, however I must
warn you. This game isn't functional.
I've had reports of it crashing many times.
I never got around to finishing the AI, it
shouldn't be working but it is...
and it's r-
uh okay alright
I won't blame you that's the only thing I saw- Ooooh
good..
ok..
alright...
judging by the wubbing sounds
there's either a hella dub-step party going on
next door or I'm about to be abducted
by aliens
or I've already been abducted by aliens  and...
everything is awful...
hello..heLLO?
Can I.. open you?
NO?
How 'bout...
no..?
Alright then..
I guess that one's just locked.
Hello, what th- what am I looking at here..?
What the-
whAT AM I LOOK-
oooh ok...
shirts.
I thought it was giant teeth there for a second there
ok...
ah
got it
alright...
cool...
i'll just-
I'll just get out of my bed room,
which is the most barren bedroom I've ever seen
in my goddamn life...
I love my single lamp... uh
I love my white everything...
ooh
*door squeaks*
Man the weather outside sure is weird...
I don't know what that's all about but ok...
Hellooooo...
Neighbors...
uhm..
I think I might be trapped in a computer...
oh no...
ok
Well, I uuuh...
The only thing I knew about this game before
I got into it was that um
it was like something about technology and glitching
and uh
ugh
seems I might be in the thick of it....
I'm just gonna call out in my own house
because that's a normal thing for humans to do-
HELLOOOOOOOO
ANY MURDERERS WANNA KILL ME?
Actually you know a power drill murderer
might be preferable to whatever
hell is in store for me...
Anti is that you???
huh?
Are you glitching up the weather outside???
oooh ya silly
biiii-
Hi
It's ok
Don't worry about anything
Don't..don't- don't ask why
i'm saying hi right now
because nothing happened
you don't need to worry about a thing
I'm totally fine.
My computer didn't crash
and then I was scared that this game was actually a virus,
and it was going to be taking over everything
that I loved and held dear.
That didn't happen at all.
Let's just carry on the game
um
Yeah I don't even remember what I'm saying 'cause
it just fought with my computer for about 10 hours
I had to pull the graphics card out because
for some reason it just
PFT
DEAD.
and I didn't know what happened
and I got super super worried about it
but,
seems to be working now I suppose
*giggles*
So that's good
*buzzing sound*
HI.
OK.
Alright then.
You don't need to do that.
To me.
For me
to me.
I keep wondering if the next step is gonna cause my computer to crash again.
It's getting a little old
but I don't want to put her to rest just yet
and I don't want this to be the game to DO IT!
*sigh*
alright then.
Probably just take a breather here
because... oooh
MAN
Something strange seems to be going on in the neighborHOOD.
Maybe I should call the Ghostbusters.
Ah yes, my favorite channel.
The "Blinding White
Sea Of Regret".
Oh my god what is happening up there?
Ok, so
if I'm not mistaken,
I must be in a computer simulation
and, uh, even though I'm ALONE IN MY OWN HOME
I- I- I'm not gonna be WEIRD
I'm just gonna shout out for anybody to be there...
HELLOOOO!
*scary sounds*
I DID NOT EXPECT A RESPOOONSE!!
Ok i'm gonna ignore that for a moment
Ya know, and maybe you could take some of these
Take them with you down to the hell hole that you came from
crawl back in there.
*kiss* *kiss*
fuck yourself
Ok..
Alright then...
Why is everything untextured?
Everything is just pure white everywhere you look.
Oh god...
Alright, fine then
I'm brave
I can face whatever that is
Probably Wolverine scratching up my door
Hellooo?
Knock like a normal person if you're not gonna KILL ME
*door slam*
Hi.
Ok.
Alright then.
Hellooo?
You having some trouble in-
"Do you feel alone out there?" Wait are you talking to me or am I talking to you?
okaaaay
alright then
I'm just gonna...
gooo on my way.
Is anybody ELSE out there?
*clanking sound*
I gotta stop yelling at my things
Hello
Hi how you doin'?
oh ok yeah... *clanking continues*
*sound of sink filling*
oh GOOD
The blood I ordered arrived.
I was wondering when that was gonna-
fill the-
Is it gonna flood my house?
Oh good
oh thank you
Good thing this key floats on BLOOD
I'll just take that
I'm not even gonna wipe it off
put that right in my pocket mmm
YEAH
That's why I ordered it
What a convenient delivery...
I'm gonna chance it one more time
IS ANYBODY - ELSE - OUT THERE
THAT WANTS TO KILL ME?
Huh
For the first time, we have silence!
Ok so I got a key
I don't think there was a door up here but...
so can I -
oh..
*door creaks*
heeeey
*scary sounds coming from the door*
UGH
I did not like opening that DOOR...
That door was too SQUANKY for me
*sound of something falling*
Can you just-
Can you just calm your damn tits!
I've had a rough time here
Ah
That's ominous...
Ok...
Why did I come in here?
Why?
Why did I need to unlock this
and go in the goddamn bathroom?
I have no reflection.
FUCK.
Alright then...
You want a piece of me?
Huh?
Anybody out there want a piece
of me?
*footsteps*
I can see something through the gap.
looks like some kind of railing or something..
Maybe more of my own house that I seem to be trapped inside of
*footsteps*
Ok, so there maybe have been...
something in here that I needed...
I can't see a THING!
It's too DARK in here!
Somebody turn on a LIGHT!
I'm gonna go back upstairs.
Better not be any "scares" waiting for me
*door slams behind him*
AAAAAAAAAAAH
FUCK YOU
...
*echoing footsteps*
HI
"You won't be for long"
What?
Alone?
Or alive?
Or slightly moist from the blood from that key?
Which IS IT?
*garbled sounds* AAAAHHHH
FUCKING FUCK YOU!
THAT'S NOT MY DESKTOP
THAT'S NOT MY DESKTOP AT ALL!!
I THINK I WOULD KNOW THAT!
HUH.
*exhales*
Fuck.
This is a puzzling piece of art..
Oka- oh hey
Ok
Alright then
OOOOH are we just gonna be looping through this
again and again and again?
Is that how we're gonna be doing it?
Oh I see how you play.
Ok
Alright then...
I think I know why this game
might have crashed my computer at some point
ba doop
oh let's GO
*door starts to creak*
OOOOOOOOOON
an adventure...
yeesh
yoosh
Ok so
What do I need to worry about?
Except for the exact same thing-
*sudden buzzing sound*
You did that before didn't ya
huh?
Imma RUUUN from yoOOU
Oh this is open now.
Well that's different.
Hello?
HellOOOOO
OOO fuck
Oh I thought I saw something in there.
Maybe I do!
Ugh
Do I?
God I thought I saw something moving in there..
Oh I don't like that!
I don't know if I saw something or not
But e- either way it scared me
Ok...
AAAAAH, GOOD
OH they gave me extra!
ooooooooohh..
Ok then...
Well that's nice.
At least it brings some color into my life.
Can I open this?
No?
Alright then.
*starts singing* doo doo DO
LA DA DE DE DE
Don't know- *singing is interrupted by loud clanking*
Fucking OK all RIGHT then
Can you just calm your TITS there?
I need to collect myself
before my heart EXPLODES!
*door slams shut*
FUCK OFF.
this porch doesn't have the way out..?
Huh.
Also-
Oh
Hi
Ok
Hello
Alright
Ok alright
I'm okay with this
how you doing
Hey neighbor!
How's it going?
"Do you feel safe?"
Ah you know...
Feel all right..
feel pretty good..
I can see behind the screen
Ok
What's behind the screen?
"It's the border keeping me from being free."
Ooooooooh
you're a
you're a darkiplier wannabe ain'tcha
"Not for long."
Are you Anti-Septiceye?
i don't know what you are
BUT YOU'RE NOT WELCOME HERE!
YOU'RE NOT WELCOME HERE
*clanking sound*
Oooook
I don't know what's happening
Oooooooh. I was here the whole time, I didn't go away
Alrighty then. Just gonna go back in my
home, that I LOVE and don't want to get
murdered in. Am I gonna get murdered in it?
In the exact same place as before?
OH, I don't want it. Ain't ready for it.
I'm a BRAVE BOY. OH what the fuck is that?
What's at the end of the HALLWAY- oh this don't look RIGHT. I don't remember this ROOM.
Ok... "Press Left Mouse to use camera" Wow, ok, oowww...
Huh boochi
Mmmhmm I like that
Huh POOF
anybody else wants a piece of this? SHAMWOW
Anybody else want a piece of THIS
SHAMWOW
arrrr
ARGENTINA!...ok alright ok alright
okay, alright, okay. SLAPCHOP
SLAPCHOP!
nobody?
nobody okay alright thats cool
Ok, alright then. That's cool, that's alright.
oxyclean, buy one get one half off, okay anyways
OXYCLEAN
Buy one get one HALF OFF!
okay anyway
FLASH
*singsongy voice* AAAaa                                ah
okay I didn't see anything in there whoa blows
Ok I didn't see anything in there.
OOooh "Close
out" okay all right
out okay all right
AYE Fucking Fucking Fuck-ing OKAY
aye fucking fucking fucking alright
*Loud Repeating Noises*
but we tried that level apparently
Ima retry that level apparently
that's what I'm gonna do- every game death
is another way of his escape or
something like that pop up you know I
could just exit out of the game but you
guys want me to keep going!
guys want me to keep going
*mumbles* 'K, so this is the way, and there is that...
okay so the idea is I think anyway there's nothing
Mmkay, so... the idea is, I think anyway, there's nothing
really else Krillin III don't know if
this for certain but it seems like the
whole concept is-  he's just gonna keep
on trying to get me to die because it
said that every game death is another
step closer for him to get free so if I
get in here- "Close out-" maybe if I just- OH
ooooh, I hit escape, oh, hi. Oooh tonight is the
night- "Come find me-" I don't know if I
wanna do that, I 'd rather stay home, eat some Cheez-Itz-
That's- that's my ideal... night in
I love that screaming you've done with the
place. That's real good decorum- oh ok I'm
here all right. Ah, oh, good I have my
camera. Hello? Anybody want a portrait
taken of them? K, and click it-  oh, there we
go, it's got a long cooldown on this one
Shabooski- okay, alright then. *singsongy voice* Sheeda leep deep a deep a deep-
BOW okay all right. Ahhhhh da beep FREEP- okay. Augh. Aw, man did you
combine a siren into a migraine inducing- OOH
hi there... I'm kind of worried about that...
not gonna lie that's a little... that's a
little concerning... What do you, uh... whatcha doin'
there... Fido- Chica? Chica, are you okay?
Chica, what happened to you? Chica? Chica...
You know what- I'm not gonna antagonize that
thing because I'm pretty sure that's
probably death. Alright, you know what, I'm
gonna go- I'm gonna go the other way
because it was a hallway okay i got a
couch in the way oh alright this looks
promising i think is good yeah okay
that's a thing is this the corner the
thing is around there's no idea then
okay all right I guess I'm fine okay
here we go then I guess I don't know
I don't like it habooski ok poof poof
ok atleast I got some semblance of safety in the form of a toilet
even though thats how I died last time
imma go this way by my bed because
that's where I feel safe okay I got
another light he's gonna guide me oh
good it's the teeth all right don't kill
you I'll come a long way I don't have to
go through all this again against funny
feeling I'm gonna have to do that if I
die okay I guess is your left what was
that ooh that looks like that looks
promising the screams are fading my skin
is clearing up my acne is gone
my spina bifida is cured oh wait
nevermind it's all ab- crumbling back
I'm a horrible monster fucking fuck
you fuck you fuck you it didn't you're a
liar you're liar oh good boot options
mono Windows 10 I want to get out I want
to get out oh ok I wonder which one i should boot
gonna boot mono that what i'd li- what is that
I don't I don't know I don't know I don't know oh I'm oh
oh it's like a fnaf mini game oh
it's so cute that's nice it's so cute
it doing it by itself I can't tell no I
didn't do that one it's doing it by
itself okay that's weird all right don't
know that's all about but I'm going to
accept this as reality what happened I
can't go backwards okay well is this is
weird can't get out of it it's
gonna get the high score i guess ok
oh don't think i can jump that one....ow my butt
I want to get out I want to get out I
wanna get out oh yeah big bubble blowing
baby whiner why don't you get over and
get out yourself why you need to use me
god damn it's the same place as before
all right let's see what the different
whoa ok wow that was fast I was not prepared for that
oh I still have this ok alright then
alright anything different in here no alright
step by step huh alrighty then step
by step what is our whoo alrighty then
step by step indeed on mate partners Oh
Ta--ah you're not gonna scare me again why
not gonna see you again but you're not
gonna scare me again I just want you to
know that okay ah well then quickly take
a picture of the other blood thing
probably probably I made my mistakes I don't know if that did anything
step by step I made my escape okay hi you gonna ask me
if I feel safe again the answer is still
gonna be yes oh hey okay that's new oh
when did I get this addition onto my
house mmm smell the spring weather oh
goody goody goody goody ok here goes get
skedaddling I'm on the street now Oh
the storms picked up a bit but I got too
much radio interference in my eye you
chose me did I I don't know kind of like
a lost puppy situation to me you entered
back in and sacrifice for bit of
yourself sure yeah okay you will be
rewarded whoa oh boy i'm sure this could
be good someday oh okay i'm impatient
guy, I can wait I guess... Alright
I'm walking down street not doing a
whole lot okay all right no lost puppy
no no no I don't want any oh hey come on
now okay what? Did I do something wrong?  what
did I fail that challENGE? I don't know what I did?
I kind olayed him oh there's more oh
there's more oh boy hey police officers
did you know that the universe is eNDIng?
maybe you should do something about that or
maybe it's all up to me for some  bizarre reason
really
and that was a bit rude no need for that I was
already going in I'm gonna shut the door oh thank
you good thing that the thing the police
officers leave the keys to all of the  secure
lock ups in their building right on the
front desk you know just in case
anybody needs them, alrighty then I don't know that did
I heard a click ehh this is baad, fuck you fine I'll take it
give me the key goddamn it fuck you and
thank you anymore lockers gonna fall
down on me huh, alright than good
what do we got here hello is this where I'm
staying? You let me out. Did I? I didn't
know you were in that one "You shall be
rewarded with the front doors" Oh Good oh
why did I come in here then is this like
a metaphorical letting out of a cave
thing I'm waiting for my eternal reward
Jafar is that you JafAR! JAFAR don't do it!
JAFAR NO! Jafar! Hang on I'm gonna lock myself in the cage
and you can't
Oh! I can't run no more! Don't do it I'm almost therrree! Augh Fuck
I knew it, I knew that's what I had to do I knew what I had to do
knew it I knew it god it's the running system
is really Borked got all my sprintingness
ohhhh It does loook bad *in sing songy voice* Oh come on! Come on!
oh fucking come on yes yeah eat a dick
Eat, eat this dick. Hello? Did I do it"
I took a selfie of my own victory there in
the middle of this jail cell look how
great I am I escaped into a cell
*Mark saying something extremely quietly* Alright ah Fucking *high pitched screams* I didn't know you were coming this way.
I don't know I'm doing a let's play
"Did I not warn you?" I don't know who I am
talking to here who are you? My name
is markiplier how you doing nice to meet
you "It's me the developer" oh cool let me
guess you're trapped in here because
your own creation uh got smarter than
you ever thought it could be and then
escaped and then caused a horrible
monstrosity "Get out while you still can"
okay all right then trying to been
trying real hard real hard man
"Oh no it's here I don't have much tuh-" blood
splatter oh that that's nice I'll have
to put a seizure warning on this 'cause
whoo all right for your own benefit I'm
a look at the ground 'cause that's that's a
lot of things going on there alrighty
then do I gotta go back in there? well
what am I gonna do when I go back? I'm
not gonna be able to do anything i'm
just gonna fall over and die I can't
fight this thing I've got no whip ehhh. okay
all right then carry on have a nice day
apparently alrighty then
so is there something new going on in
here that I need to know about oh gee
thank you this is open that's nice but
these are all closed except for this
and this. hello?
oh uh hey I need that
well that's gone okay never mind then. why I this never I
don't know what to do about--- holy fucking holy hell
hi can I help you I don't want any okay
alright I'm gonna jump off into the abyss
here wee oh oh okay you tell me that was
the correct answer oh yeah how did you
get here I don't know man I don't know
it's me again good developer yeah I
suspected as much seems like you're the
only way to get rid of this thing is to
kill it oh just like most things "let's
get you out of here first though okay
there are three big buttons in the maze
ahead pressing all three will reset your
computer and allow us to progress but we
beware it is also in there" okay all right
game on then I guess god dammit it ends
with a maze what kind of  douchery is this there's
a big button pressed it nailed that one
let me give a high five for myself good
job markiplier keep going get the other
ones ignore the laser flight going on
in the sky above anyone else see a big
button out there anybody have oh I see
another big button mm-hmm that's a good
one that's nice good job markiplier oh
shit I am fucked
fucking goddamn it but what are you
supposed to do about that ah titties this
is legitimately my top speed at the
moment trying to go faster but it's not
working it's not working last button
baby ah come on, c'mon! I did it my gosh you're
oh I did it!" Is that it?" It better be!
mmm I did it, I'm the best! "Did we do it?"
I don't know you're the developer you tell
me I ain't got a clue I'm just trying my
best here man just trying to live day by
day day by day "No, no it isn't..." of course
not why would it be? check back in the
full game" with what check back in the
full what are you talking about  "please
consider rating on" Oh are you being
serious or is this mono trying to get
out of there because he's trying to get
you guys to spread the game is that how
that is working I see through your ruse
here oh I see what you're doing oh
that's what it meant by extended demo
well holy shit that was just a demo wow
that's a pretty impressive demo when it
usually comes to demos in indie horror
games it's like a 10 minute 15 minute if
that adventure that was like a
full-sized in the organ and pretty good
too with good animations good scares a
lot of good things going on here so
heck yeah I'm gonna vote for that on Steam
greenlight but bit of a dickish place
to end it for me after all the things i did
but either way still good so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought of this down in the
comments below this is pretty good it
got me a quite a few times so let me
know if it got you too thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye!
*Dubstep ish electronic music plays in the background*